un mois ce chemin-là
je serai première fiche de la croque pas
de la musique des rires et des histoires
une recette que les petits adorent
chaque année le Centre Hospitalier de
Versailles propose un spectacle aux
enfants malades ou hospitalisés cet
après-midi là sous les feux des
projecteurs c'est le petit chaperon
rouge qui est mis en scène j'attendais
ça depuis quelques jours ou quand on a
reçu l'invitation j'étais très content
de recevoir un cadeau de voir un
spectacle d'avoir un goûter c'est très
bien avec l'hôpital face à avec la taxe
cyberata quand même c'est très bien une
initiative de rire 78 l'association
rocancourtoise veut propager la joie
dans les Yvelines rire pour guérir est
une de leurs actions elle propose des
moments divertissants pour les enfants
hospitalisés c'est un rendez-vous qui
est très important pour les enfants pour
les enfants et pour leur famille
d'ailleurs pas seulement pour les
enfants parce que c'est un temps de
réunion un petit peu en dehors de la
maladie dans le contexte quand même de
l'hôpital c'est ils viennent voir le
spectacle de l'hôpital mais ils viennent
pas pour une consultation donc on les
voit de manière très plaisante il y a
pas de Verdi qui a pas de choses
désagréables attendues des cours
l'association nous a commandé le
spectacle parce que on joue beaucoup
dans les écoles mais c'est vrai que
jouer aussi pour des enfants qui sont
voilà qui sont suivis à l'hôpital c'est
voilà c'est hyper important leur
apporter un petit peu de voilà un peu de
baume au cœur un peu de Noël un peu de
joie c'est enfin c'est vraiment on est
on est vraiment ravis de jouer pour eux
aujourd'hui à ce jour 117 spectacles ont
été présentés dans 23 hôpitaux et
cliniques des Yvelines